deutsche fast herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video wir sind hier im jump
haus in köln und ich habe mir heute
etwas besonderes überlegt und zwar
treten zwei teams gegeneinander an vier
youtuber in jeden teams und wir haben
vier aufgaben die wir bewältigen müssen
thema 1 und tier 2
[Musik]
ok los geht's wie gespannt wir heute
gewinnen kann unsere ersten zwei
kandidaten aus wir haben noch keine team
ok für team klar sie tritt jetzt an und
führt ihn bei sebastian die erste
disziplin und ich muss sagen nehmt eure
plätze ein superschönes aus und dann
gucken wir welches team den ersten punkt
holen kann
denn die beiden stehen in der mitte
anhalten und jemand getroffen wurde
heißt es sofort punkt für team das eine
team dementsprechend 32 perfekt
wird langsam anstrengend wird langsam
auf dem balkon
fr
[Applaus]
der erste punkt geht an ziehen bei wir
gehen direkt zur nächsten aufgabe ich
bin einfach drauf ich unsere thomas
alles wir sehen im bösen
ich bin die böse alles klar wir kommen
zur zweiten aufgabe zur battle box mit
einem balken in der mitte und zwei
spieler werden gegeneinander antreten
und probieren den jeweils anderen vom
balken runter zu werfen mit diesen
beiden schön stockschläge körper ist
auch so gut aus dem kreis max und hielt
ihm war klar
[Applaus]
max mit druck keine punkte eintrug
da steht jetzt 1 1 die nächste aufgabe
ist basketball warum haben sie
eigentlich vier aufgaben dann kann es 2
2 ausgehen aber das schöne dann haben
uns alle lieb ist okay leute jetzt
machen wir den basketball challenge und
dieses mal geht es darum wer in einer
minute mehr körperschaft aber erst
kämpfen abwägen und das sind fifa
konkurrenten
wer der der jetzt gewinnt ist besser in
fifa hat den längeren gut dass immer ein
video über nachhilfe teurer hier vorne
in diesem sarg liegen drei bälle drin
und wir stoppen die zeit man darf immer
einmal laufen reingehen korb werfen wer
als erstes drei körbe hat hat gewonnen
wer fängt an
für team kraft es geht los sind 3213
vorbereiten ja
ich habe nichts auf ein verbrechen
was halt vorbei
[Musik]
wir sind bei solchen kunst weiterhin
mein gott ist das schlecht
bei einer minute ab teilweise ein
[Musik]
wo eine minute 13 sekunden jetzt muss
man auch schneller sein ob das was wird
weiß ja nicht ich hab ihm kassentisch
beendet man wo bist du schon aufgeregt
dass ich dir helfen ich finde hier die
runde 2 timo 321 co nein da muss ich
nicht anregen
[Musik]
bei zehn sekunden sieht sehr gut aus für
unser team
[Musik]
22 14 10 bei 32 sekunden das war ein
bisschen schneller update was sagst du
zu lange leisten
mir fehlen die worte einfach okay jetzt
die alles entscheidende runde habe ich
einfach gerade entschieden alles was
bisher passiert ist haben jetzt wie
manager parcours endrunde und da
entscheidet sich wer gewinnt wir müssen
eine sache wissen regie also dass es
keine ironie ist richtig erst richtig
aber du musst eine sache wissen dave ist
auch richtig gut aber release noch ein
gewinn her richtig
aber dann macht man weiter
das gehört dazu das alles entscheidende
rennen von macht weiter
ok jungs seid ihr bereit das finale
[Applaus]
14 sekunden dürfen sie können 16 ja
16,99 ist ja wirklich los dass der weg
nicht laut aber wir haben die regel
nicht weiter erklärt du kannst du gleich
machen leute der alles entscheidenden
okay leute ihr wisst dass vielleicht
schon aber der sieger des heutigen tages
fielen bald jemand großartig aber der
sieg geht heute an euch spielen alle für
ist dabei nicht dabei sein und wir sehen
uns mal wieder machen